how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to the MCU and today we have a
full plot like a supposed plot league
for Thor love and thunder now it's
pretty tricky when it comes to plot
leaks there have been many different
plot leaks for many different movies and
shows over time however some of them
have been true
and today's plot leak comes from 4chan
by somebody who claims to be working on
the film currently now this is the same
place where we got the accurate plot
leaked for infinity war and endgame it
was posted on 4chan I did a video about
both of them infinity war ant in game
and they both ended up being true and if
a true plot leak was going to pop up it
would pop up on 4chan because it's
anonymous and I have to tell you this
plot leaked seems very very real so if
you do not want to know anything about
for love and thunder including the
villain that Christian Bale is going to
be playing in the movie Jane Foster's
role as Lady Thor but guardians of the
galaxy in the film as well and anything
else this is your official spoiler
warning if you are new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all content relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so the
validity of this plot League comes from
the fact that it is very very
descriptive and everything involved in
this plot leak makes perfect sense for
the direction of the movie so we'll go
over it in its entirety and then we'll
break it down so it starts off by saying
Christian Bale is playing the main
villain gore in this version gore is an
alien whose race was slaughtered by
hella he blames the Asgardians and after
years of searching retrieved the nekross
sword to wipe them out thou'rt is having
intergalactic adventures with the
guardians of the galaxy when Gore
attacks and wounds him then announces
that he will kill the remaining as
Guardians on earth Thor goes there to
protect them with rocket and Groot
when he gets to earth for can't find
Gore so he's forced to ask Jane Foster
for help for sword is powered by dark
energy and Jane might be able to trace
it Jane Foster is now working for sword
the sentient world observation and
response department and director Abigail
brand is not happy when Thor shows up
needing help
Thor Jane and Abigail brand go to new
Asgard where they reunite with Valkyrie
and a timed
placed loki who ends up a prisoner there
after whatever happens in his spinoff
series along with loki is a new time
displaced mule near that doesn't answer
to thor because it's under a different
spell when they get to new Asgard they
find out that Gord tricked Thor into
leading him to new Asgard and destroys
it with his army of shadow berserkers
during the chaos gene wields Mjolnir and
fence off Gore for the time being
Abigail brand places the Asgardians
under swords protection at an outpost
near a small town in Oklahoma Thor
trains Jane to control mule near and
they reconnect Valkyrie and Abigail also
develop a bond Loki ends up escaping and
he joins forces with Gore to use Jane's
research on dark energy and harness it
through the necro sword to defeat Thor
dark energy has time altering properties
that Loki wants this all leads to a
major battle between Thor and Jane
against Gore across time and space while
in the meantime Valkyrie and brand lead
the s guardians and sword in a battle
against the shadow berserkers to defend
earth and humanity during the battle
rocket and Groot must deal with a dark
energy singularity that gore creates
before it consumes the planet and Loki
pursues his own agenda during that time
as well gore is going to be mocap or
motion captured but his pre nekross
sword form is going to be human looking
aka Christian Bale the dark energy
mutates him and he becomes a monster and
gets more monstrous as he absorbs more
of it Abigail brand is the other major
role left to cast Marvel Studios is
looking at actresses like Jody comer and
Vanessa Kirby for the role since the
character is supposed to appear in
several movies just like Nick Fury in
the film rocket and Groot are supporting
characters the rest of the Guardians
star-lord Drax mantis and nebula are
cameos there are some talks about having
them join in the final battle of the
film but nothing is final yet Gamora
won't show up in the film because her
story is reserved for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 for love and thunder is set
to have the same comedic tone as thor
ragnarok the idea is to leave the door
open for Chris Hemsworth and Natalie
Portman to return for more but also wrap
up their character arcs in case they
decide to stop after this Gore is going
to kill either Korg or meek during the
attack on new Asgard but he hasn't yet
decided on who Korg would definitely be
more impactful but he likes playing the
character and that's it for this plot
leak and there are a lot of things that
we need to go over here a lot of things
that connect to the comics and connect
to the future of the MCU let's start off
with Kristian Belle Plaine Gore now a
lot of people have expected Gore to be
the main villain as far as the Thor
storyline goes he just makes perfect
sense and if this leak ends up being
true they really are going to stick
pretty close to his origins in the
comics and the comics Gore has a pretty
tragic backstory his wife dies and his
children die as well Gore's entire race
worships the gods but when Gore loses
his family he claims that they cannot be
real or else they would help him Gore is
then exiled and cast out while exiled
while walking through the desert about
to die two gods fell out of the sky a
Dark Eldar god called null and a gold
armored purple skinned god realizing
that gods did exist but didn't answer
his prayers and help people he vowed to
go out and kill them all Knowle had a
dark necro sword which Gore would take
from him and this would become the
all-black necro sword and it would have
the ability to kill gods now this is his
origin in the comics and as you can see
from this pot leaked they're going to
remain pretty true to it hella who is a
god is supposed to be responsible for
killing all of his people so therefore
he will vow to go and kill all the other
gods as Guardians specifically because
hello was Ana's Guardian so gore is
going to get the neck restored and then
head to earth now it also says that
Gore's going to be a motion captured
villain which makes a lot of sense
because that's actually Christian Bale's
preference and plain gore actually makes
a lot of sense for him as well because
he has already said that he doesn't want
to be in a film that's going to require
him to commit for several different
movies he pretty much said he was done
with that after filming Batman Begins
Batman The Dark Knight and Batman The
Dark Knight Rises so a villain that is
motion captured and only in one movie is
perfect for him to play so it says the
film starts off with Thor having
intergalactic adventures with the
guardians of the galaxy and since this
film is supposed to have the same tone
as Ragnarok we can imagine it's going to
be pretty hilarious and of course this
is where the movie is going to start
because at the end of endgame for left
with the guardians of the galaxy gore
will then find Thor and he'll attack him
and
wound him and then head to earth for new
Asgard because remember Gore is vowing
to kill all Asgardian gods
hello killed his family so therefore in
return he's going to kill all the
Asgardians so he finds Thor wounds him
and then heads to earth to kill the rest
of them and this is how Thor goes back
to earth and rocket and Groot as well as
Vin Diesel has recently confirmed that
the guardians are going to play a part
in Thor love and thunder now there's a
few key parts here in this plot leak one
is him going to Jane Foster because of
dark energy we all wondered how Jane
Foster is going to reenter the picture
especially after Thor was pretty upset
about her in Avengers end game are you
crying but he's going to go to her for
help and she's going to now be working
for sword now sword was introduced kind
of at the end of Spider Man fire for hum
Nick Fury was on the peak not to mention
we also have confirmation of sword from
leaked photos from the set of the one
division series and Jane Foster was
working with shield before so it would
make sense that she could just go over
to sword and this brings in Abigail
Brandt who is the head of sword now
what's really interesting about Abigail
brand is that she is actually a mutant
she has the ability of pyrokinesis
meaning that she can create and control
fire now it's unclear on whether or not
she's going to be a mutant in the film
but considering the fact that Kevin
Feige has announced that the x-men are
going to be coming to the MCU
and if they're going to introduce
Abigail brand as the commander of sort
it just makes sense that she is going to
be a mutant
so a mutant will be in for and then
after they go to new Asgard which was a
trap by Gore Abigail and sword are going
to protect the remaining as guardians
another huge thing is Mew NER being
brought to the current timeline by Loki
this is something that we knew was going
to happen we've known it for a while but
we were confused as to how Loki would be
able to bring me linear we expected that
somehow along his journey he would
become worthy to lift it but this plot
lead claims that there is a different
spell on it and the worthiness spell is
not enchanted on it now it doesn't say
what this spell is but whatever it is
Jane Foster is able to lift milner and
use it to fight off Gore
that combined with training from Thor
himself Jane Foster will become the
female version of Thor and this answers
the question that we've all been
wondering as to how Jane is worthy
enough to lift millionaire but also how
she comes to be in the position now Loki
escaping and joining forces with Thor is
typical Loki because we have to remember
this is not the same Loki who died in
Avengers infinity war this is 2012 Loki
this is immature Loki who hasn't gone
through all the things that he went
through in the current MCU timeline and
he's still pretty much not necessarily
evil but definitely an antihero and just
like he joined forces with vanos and the
past he joins forces with Gore in the
current time now it says that Gore is
going to have his Berserker army and
this is also something that comes from
the comics with the all-black neck
ressort he's able to create these shadow
berserkers and of course it's Marvel
we're going to have a big army fight at
the end of the movie but this won't be
the main battle the main battle will
take place between for Jane Foster and
gore and their fight is said to take
place across space and time this is
directly from the comics as well in fact
for teams up with other versions of
himself to kill gore and that's
basically what's going on here another
version of Thor is Jane Foster Thor at
least as far as these movies are
concerned and then like I mentioned
before you have rocket and Groot that
are going to be along for the majority
of the movie the other as guardians of
the galaxy are just going to appear in
the beginning so let me know what you
think about this plot League if this
ends up being true would you be okay
with this happening and Thor love and
thunder let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll forth